hello yet before starting today's
session let me make a small announcement
so in the evening after the second talk
let's say around 5:40 we will have a
informal discussion session with today's
speakers and last week speakers so let
me start by introducing professor Sergey
guca from El Tech and he will tell us
about esto ality in geometric langlands
well thank you very much for
introduction and more importantly thank
you to all of the organizers especially
to Ashman for his very hard work to
invite me here and I'm excited to learn
many new things during this week so I
have to start by surf apologizing right
to pay that and I'm making it clear that
today I'll focus on some physics
introduction to geometric Langlands or
physics approach or introduction to
physics approach to geometric langlands
and this will be different subject from
other lectures that I'm going to give
later
so other lectures different subjects and
also
a different style today this is supposed
to be a survey so my job is not to
explain anything really and just to
connect as many things as possible and
here the goal will actually be to
explain things so it will be much more
pedagogical so the reason I mention it
now is that if you feel completely lost
or and interested in today's lecture it
may not mean the same for tomorrow and
vice-versa so before I get to physics
interpretation of geometric langlands
which roughly will be second half of the
talk I thought it may make sense to to
motivate why geometric langlands is
interesting in the first place and it's
not so much for specific form of the
conjectures which I'll state at some
point but rather for connections that it
makes between different subjects which
include number theory so that's one
subject that's our goes into Langlands
program in fact non-recurring grants
program that's classical then there is
geometry even different type of geometry
that goes into geometric version of the
program and representation theory
so the usual leg length correspondence
of number theorists takes different
parts from from there's different
subjects and blends them together in a
rather surprising interesting way so the
reason people are interested is
precisely for this network of
connections I'm not going to be able to
explain many of them but I'll try to
give you a hint of how each one of these
arrows looks like so I'll give you
examples from several connections and as
you may notice physics is not part of it
so then but two of the items from the
title of this program are so namely it's
called quantum field geometry and
representation theory and geometry and
representation we are on the board so
physics will come later
or quantum field theory will come later
so first I'll try to focus let's say on
on perhaps this connection between
number theory and geometry and this will
be topic number one so there are many
subjects and number theory work geometry
or you could say emergent geometry comes
out out of the blue as a surprise and
what them has to do with the theory of
modular forms so modular forms are
function which enjoy nice
transformations with respect to SLG or
various subgroups of else L to Z or
whereas other analogous groups so it
means that if you have some function of
tau F of tau then F of a tau plus B
divided by a plus D or C tau plus D is
up to some pre factor
is the same as f of tau and in number
theory you get various interesting
subfields of this area depending on what
exactly you require here is a
transformation the most classical
example is that appears in most of the
textbooks is where you have CTL + D to
the power K and this power K
is called eaters of the modular form and
in particular it means if so notice that
a and B do not appear here on the
right-hand side which means that allowed
to shift tell by any integer which means
that such a function f of tau actually
can be written as a power series in
variable Q so sum over n say from 1 to
infinity and Q to the N where Q is
exponential of 2 pi I tell so writing it
as such with integer values of n will
essentially guarantee that such a
function is invariant under T
transformation with shifts now by plus 1
but of course then you have to ask when
does it will also enjoy transformation
with respect to s element of SL to Z or
corresponding subgroup so that's a
non-trivial question it's interesting to
study spaces of such modular forms of
different weights and again it's a very
typical subject in number theory and
first I choose one and for experts that
means I'm focusing on cost forms but at
elf press again this is servi or I'll
suppress the differences between bundles
and sheaves cos forms and such so
therefore I'll try to speak fluently
sometimes really meaning what I say but
suppressing the reason why so the
statement I'm aiming for is better
phrase with forecast forms right so and
again note will approach many of these
topics from vary so I'll try to
emphasize the most essential ones and
ask most kind of essential questions
focusing on on big picture so the big
picture is important that the way this
modular forms are defined and that's why
I decided to review for your definition
makes it completely non-obvious
that some of those coefficients am have
to be integers so that of course comes
out quite not always by the way but
quite often and as both of our morning
speakers already emphasized earlier
today if you see some integers in
expansion of a function you have to ask
yourself what this integer is accounting
so where are they coming from
when they're counting so to answer this
question in this set up it's convenient
to take function and transform it a
little bit so there is a so called
Mellin transform now this is part of a
much more general story which this is
named usually used in number theory
textbooks and textbooks on complex
analysis or on analysis you see exactly
the same transform under a different
name it's called the real transforms and
this connection or this interpretation
actually makes nice contact with yet
another subject which is so called
resurgent analysis that's not
but I mention it now because there will
be couple of other places where
analogous phenomena will appear and what
is the melon transform so if you have a
function f like ours then Mellin
transform of that function is basically
the integral from 0 to infinity of f of
X X to the power s DX over X they serve
integral so you can introduce
logarithmic variable it log of X and
rewrite it as exponential of s times
that variable there are several
different ways but you can try to apply
this sort of transform to modular form
to learn something interesting about it
and what you learn is that the resulting
function usually has nice interesting
analytic properties on a complex plane
as a function of complex valued argument
s and this gives you the l series but to
be a little bit more precise I'll be
interested in so called your flare l
Sirius attached to our function f of tau
thinking that I'm mostly interested in
modular forms and the definition you can
also make the following definition that
f of sorry L function of our F as a
function of s is basically sum over n
same from 1 to infinity of n over N to
the power s thank you so
this is essentially this closely-related
causing of the melon transformed
there are usually two versions of L
functions one is usually called lambda
that has nicer properties if you
interested in behavior on complex plane
the other is L which is closer to
interpretation of integrality of the
coefficients where I'm aiming at and
then it turns out that if you repackage
information about your original modular
form of weight K what happens is that
this can be written as a product and
this is yet another connection to other
lectures that you'll see over and over
again in fact both of our morning
speakers kind of used it then sometimes
if you have a function it's convenient
and it's complicated enough it's
convenient to rewrite the sum which is
how it's given to you in the form of the
product and again though both speak this
morning didn't really emphasize that
that was and what was going on so this
psalm which looks somewhat complicated
constructed out of their original input
can be written as a product and the
product is over Prime's P of the form 1
divided by 1 minus AP e to the power
minus s plus e to the K minus 1 minus 2
s and now you can ask does it bring us
any closer to interpretation of this
coefficients AP and the answer is yes
that for K equals 2 so when when the
weight is equal to 2 then 1 plus P minus
the APS which appear here in
denominators are precisely the numbers
of points on elliptic curve defined over
FP so here is an example
rather famous example where geometry
appears in a number theory problem kind
of out of the blue and what I just
reviewed so let's see is a statement of
famous taniyama well conjectures it's
yes I believe so yeah so here I'm
suppressing primes of bed reduction and
and all of that so I'm assuming that
right so there is an interesting story
what happened if your equation for
elliptic curve and P have something in
common mainly that's some kind of primal
reduction occurs but if that doesn't
happen so that kind of degenerate
phenomenon then basically what this says
is that all a ends can be expressed in
terms of a PS and that's actually how
this first appeared and the works of
hacky and that gave rise to the hacky
theory so that's that's actually what
this formula is saying that there is a
way to package information about and
just in terms of ApS for crime and
that's again the jr. phenomenon that
this is trying to convey so a theorem
which used to be in Yama very conjecture
say it again yes well this is almost
like this is essentially the zeta
function right so that's why it's not
identical to zeta function itself
function but as a close cousin so indeed
that's so yeah this is closely related
to theory of Zeta functions and Way
conjectures which you should tell you
how to factor the denominator but that's
a bit different so that's that's not
identity also don't try to expect that
this should be really cool okay so
what's the statement of the conjecture
is that for every elliptic curve e over
Q there exists a cusp form so that's a
precise statement but again I don't want
to focus on all such details I want to
convey the flavor because if I focus too
much on details I'll never again
anywhere off of way to for some conquer
and subgroup office L to Z gamma 0 of n
such that L function for this cost form
for this modular form is the same as L
function of elliptic curve essentially
defined by the right hand side of that
equation so it basically says that this
phenomena should happen and there is a
nice map between such modular forms and
geometry or adult geometry over finite
fields for elliptic curves
[Music]
so this is example of a connection
between number theory and geometry where
geometry pops out of the blue and this
leads to an interesting connection you
can naturally op how to generalize this
to higher weight K so here I presented
for you a little bit of the story for
general K and only in the end
specialized to case of way to yet if you
ask this question that actually is the
subject of active research so this is
this sometimes goes by the name of
modularity conjectures and requires a
lot more technology the basic idea is
that this weight is correlated with the
dimension of algebraic you're writing so
elliptic curves appear only because
we're in a smallest interesting weight
and if you ask for higher weights you'll
be dealing with algebraic geometry over
fields in variety of high dimension so
let me give you another example of such
connection between other topics involved
here and what I'm aiming at is give you
a flavor of what kind of subjects appear
how they connect possibly other talks
and so that then we can see later
physics incarnation of some of this
phenomena and their analogues so all of
this language correspondence is really
about analogies of various types so
number
- is got to be let's say between
representation theory and geometry where
the statement would be that geometry of
various varieties or some geometric
objects on various varieties have to do
with representations if varieties have
something to do with the group so
suppose for example the G as will be in
the rest of my talk compactly group if
you're not a representation here is
think of as you - that's good enough in
fact that's that's going to reach enough
story continue the discussion and then
the usual Borel abode serine theorem
said that finite dimensional
representations of of gene can be
identified with spaces of sections of
one bundle or more Jerry
bundles on gmod various subgroups gmod
age and this kind of statement is baby
version of a more general program which
usually goes by the name of orbit method
and more generally sometimes referred as
one of the main problems in geometric
representation theory that says roughly
the following that if you have so
geometry of orbit or conjugacy class G
of the group G knows and there is a
connection between representations of G
so in fact here it's not necessarily if
it is compact it basically boils down to
a theorem so it is Borel well but serum
but if G is non compact and later on I
will use the following notations that G
C will be the complexification of G and
G sub R will be some real form of C then
in those cases there is no
all-encompassing theorem but there is an
all-encompassing theory developed by
David Ragan and many others that
connects the geometry of some orbits or
conjugacy classes or more precisely
geometry of various bundles on those
conjugacy classes and representations of
of G
so I'll give you an example in a second
I'll go to the other part of the board
but just to list one more item here of
the same flavor these are all pretty
much the same statements in increasing
degree of complexity starting with the
simplest which is the statement of Borel
well pod theorem then this more general
study if you try to make it a little bit
more precise and I'll mention the reason
why you need that you introduce your
more sophisticated to object so here I
try to phrase it in terms of something
fairly familiar but then very quickly it
leads you to notion of so-called sheets
which are finite unions of orbits of
conjugacy classes and also leads to
statements such as what's known as
geometric syntactic correspondence which
is rather in evolved version of such
statement that says if you're interested
in representations of the group G then
they have something to do with I'll say
bundles that is of course not quite
correct again I'm using
oversimplification from my earlier
disclaimer on what's called a finebros
Manion of
you can fit as a usual verse Mannion we
are all familiar with usual verse
Mannion which is basically space of say
K dimensional planes in n-dimensional
vector space but if you try to make
analogous notion over function fields
you naturally run to to the notion of a
fine investment
so one of the general themes in
geometric representation theory is to
connect representations of some group G
it real compact or complex to typically
bundles on some spaces so that's nice a
very general form now I'll give you an
example of which feeds in some sense to
most of the period on the blackboard
what is an orbit for a conjugacy class
it basically means that you can pick an
element X are they in Li algebra or from
the group G and start acting on it with
the group G by by usual a joint record
joint action so this gives you an orbit
or in the group Theory case and
exponentiated version the conjugacy
class and simple example is again if say
G is asked you to you can pick any
element in a skew and try to run this
procedure say if you identity element if
X happens to be identity then doesn't
matter how you conjugate it gonna
produce the same element so that's an
example where this conjugacy class will
orbit will be just a point because
action will will keep the identity but
if you pick generic element of su 2 what
will happen that you can reach any other
element of s you to by a joint action as
long as elements of the group that you
are using do not commute with a given
element X and for generic X there is
usually just you one subgroup of ask you
to which commutes with it so you quickly
learn that in this case always simply
going to be
I'm a genius pace as you tune what you
want which is precisely the same thing
as CP 1 and as a result and realize
you're familiar representations of SU 2
find a dimensional representation so
fast you two sections of various bundles
on CP 1 so that's that's a typical
statement that you get on this way so in
particular you can get representations
such as trivial a joint of su 2 and so
on and so forth the familiar sequence of
representation now why do we need more
sophisticated technology again I don't
have a lot of time to explain it but
there is an interesting phenomenon that
happens here that suppose you have some
representation V of su 2 and you know
that a three dimensional representation
is here inside okay then in case of
finite dimensional representations of
compact groups gee what happens is that
there is no other choice for it to be a
direct summoned in V but in general if
we move away from finite dimensional
representations of compact groups that's
not the case so what may happen is that
you have for example representation say
two plus three or it's analog and it
sits inside V in such a way that this
exact sequence does not split so two and
three and whatever else appears here are
not necessarily direct summons okay so
this is quite interesting phenomenon and
it leads you to naturally leads you to
notion of extensions extensions of
representations and requires a little
bit more sophisticated technology to
describe because now you can ask well if
you told me that representation can be
realized as some sort of geometric
object how do i form an extension what
does it mean how does John
or if like that and phenomena partial
answers or maybe complete answers to
this question you'll see in talks of
citta Shinawatra and possibly
duque who will discuss an obvious
phenomena happen in geometry pitch and
moduli space which will appear with a
later in our discussion and it should be
interpreted as bound States bound state
formation of brains or EPS objects which
so physicists probably can relate to
this line mathematicians can certainly
be more happy with the extensions of
representations but they're actually
similar phenomena if you use this
context of geometric representation
theory okay any any questions so these
are different examples so twelve row
here so they're roughly in what I
mentioning is three types of statements
and increasing degree of complexity one
as a classical theorem and as well
define it has very specific set of
assumptions the other is more of a
program again which goes under this
world orbit method and which has the
following that if you form such a card
is a class or orbit it always happens to
be nice phase space symplectic manifold
that you can quantize so thinking about
it as phase space in classical mechanics
there in quantum mechanics and then you
obtain the corresponding representation
as a result of quantization so basically
that's the philosophy here so then there
are two actually different but related
notions or I'm just throwing key words
which are trying to make this program
more systematic so that it could be is
this as a theory
as a general statement with specified
assumptions in one form it requires you
introducing this notion of sheets by
borough which combines several conjugacy
classes together sometimes so what I
just said is a little bit oversimplified
for general theorem and the other is a
somewhat geometric statement of
geometric saty correspondence is also an
upgrade but in a slightly different
direction that involve which is be kind
of built in this extensions are in place
right away and has to do with
categorical structure namely there is a
tensor product on representations and
morphisms that it takes into account ok
so again this is just a glimpse of what
connecting between in this case geometry
and representation theory typically
looks like and it's somewhat surprising
that there is such a nice marriage
between two different subjects ok
questions ok so now I proceed to number
three and for number three I have
nothing left but to talk about this
relation which is religion between
number three and representation theory
and actually I'll just say the one of
the statements of conjectures one of the
conjectures in the language program but
I want to emphasize is the difference
between the classical case and geometric
case so yeah geometry appearing in a
priori they're very different that's
that's a really good question
so I just took two random examples which
I try to cover as much territory as you
can see and make as many connections
as I can so unfortunately this geometry
is not the same but we could have tried
to relate geometry of those varieties
which were just arrays to number theory
that would still work I mean there would
be still a night fine that's just a poor
choice of example okay right so in
the statement of some of the leg length
conjecture is there are several
different versions which work at
different levels so first of all you can
consider finite fields and make a set of
statements so then you can consider a
number fields such as say Q extended by
square root of minus 2 that's an example
so then you can go to function fields
where things start becoming dimensional
and finally reach geometric langlands
and physics as the top of this program
and again there are different levels the
reason I mention this is that even the
statement I'm going to phrase next and
be formulated and each of these
categories and this direction brings us
closer to physics but this opposite
direction if you go up is what's usually
called classical so this is just help
for the terminology classical version of
length lens conjectures when you try to
go away from function fields or anything
infinite dimensional work ideally with
either finite fields a number fields
kind of like we saw in our questions a
moment ago so and in each of this
framework so I'm going to make a
statement which can be equally phrased
in all of these different versions
first rather far from from the bottom
and that's that's precisely the
statement of one of the leg lengths
conjectures which says that n
dimensional representations which I am
going to call Sigma of the Galois group
of the closure of F over F correspond to
irreducible of morphic representations
which I'm going to call pi of GL n and
over what field you define both sides is
is again depends on where exactly you
want to work with but this is kind of
for for the survey is a type of question
that usually is taking as formulation so
again I'm not going to explain all this
words but I'll explain some bits and
pieces for example instead of telling
you the precise definition of Auto
morphic representation and suffices to
say that it can be realized in a nice
class of functions on a homogeneous
space kind of like notions of bundles
that we saw earlier and yeah this is
obviously number theory side this is
more representation here aside if you
wish and that's the statement of the
correspondence now by itself it wouldn't
be as interesting if it didn't come with
reach additional structure and in
particular
so Sigma helps to PI and that's what I
want to record and in particular what
happens is that on this set of auto
morphic representations of GL n you have
a nice action of algebra which is very
large and interesting and it's called
spherical check your algebra so in the
setting spiracle Hecky algebra is
nothing the algebra of symmetric
polynomials so this is a statement of
so-called Satake isomorphism which says
that in case of GL m this is nothing but
C of Z 1 plus minus 1 and so on up to Zn
plus minus n symmetrized with respect to
SN and and there is a corresponding so
if you think of it as algebra that that
act on on the subjects and in good
situation which is called corresponds to
2 underneath I'd choice of such a
reducible representation PI it can be
nicely matched to certain data on the
left hand side so again I just without
deep explanation I want to say that
there are certain parameters or
invariants that you're supposed to match
across this correspondence so on this
side these are called eigen values so
set of strength parameters alcohol then
z1 of PI and so on the end of pi
or supposed to nicely match to analogous
parameters z1 of Sigma up to Zn of Sigma
which are defined completely differently
on the left-hand side and these are
called hekia heigen values and these are
called
for being as eigen values of course I
realize that not giving you full
definitions but the reason I mention
this is because first of all I want to
say that there are certain things that
are supposed to match and actually there
are physical counterparts I can explain
this is a little bit sorry of my domain
but another reason I mentioned this is
that this is attached to name of
Ramanujam and I thought that this would
be a crime if I give lecture and missed
opportunity to mention it in the context
of geometric langlands correspondence
and it also gives me an opportunity to
illustrate this scenery between optical
versus closer to physics or geometric
version what because theorem which just
like in case of 20ml conjectures used to
be conjecture and in fact it's
conjecture of Ramanujan Patterson but
now it's a
which has that absolute value of the
sea-ice of pi is equal to 1 for 4
underneath I'd or good choice of this
automatic representation PI so again it
mentioned this before it and explained
an aside that it's it's something nice
but that's one of the statements which
carries the name of Ramanujan but it's
actually so this I'm not going to
explain but I'm going to explain its
classical version of this conjecture
which actually is very concrete and
recognizable just like everything an
usual standard number theory that so
this is called just Ramanujan conjecture
that's proved by the Ling and it's a
statement about essentially discriminant
function so if you take Q and product
over m from 1 to infinity of 1 minus Q
to the M to the 24th power and again use
the same trick or same principle where
it's often used useful ID or good idea
to convert someone to a product on
product into a sum so you can write this
as a sum over and from 1 to infinity
coefficients 12n due to the n then this
conjecture states that tau of P absolute
value is less than or equal to 2 times e
to the 11 halves and sometimes is called
11 house conjecture or prime P
so this is something very concrete again
now it's a theorem due to Deline and
even though it does not look immediately
exactly like this it's it's supposed to
be a classical version of that statement
so now I want to come to this statement
of Langlands conjecture and rewrite that
gradually transform it in the language
that eventually brings us to physics so
a first thing to do is to try to
formulate it not for gln but for more
general groups that's one of the first
places for Langlands correspondence for
lingua notion of language dual group my
peers and are there any questions before
I move on to the second part so I'm
essentially done with brief overview of
phenomena that Connect number theory
geometry and representation theory and
in the rest of the talk my goal is to
take this phenomena and show you the
geometric or if you wish physical
counterpart
I know but isn't it not the 24th power
just not just this product itself yeah
so it you'll be counting like partitions
over I don't know that's a good question
and yeah honestly I don't know some of
this also connects to convene a tour X
which I guess could be at another corner
and okay so I'm going to take this
statement and overlay it with couple of
equivalent gents or slightly different
versions but the reason I stated without
deep explanation some of the classical
story is I can make analogies and tell
you what elements of the classical story
what becomes of them in the geometric or
perhaps even in the physical context so
with a broad brush this aside is called
go outside this side is called Auto
morphic sides for hopefully for reasons
which somewhat obvious even though I
didn't explain those details and what
the conjecture tries to do is to
associate some presentation PI to
representation Sigma in such a way that
Stern invariants match with respect to
spherical Hecky algebra action so all of
the statements which I just recap have
their analog and the geometric world and
that's that's what we're going to
discuss so first thing as I already
alluded to is to try to take just this
classical statement of Langlands
conjectures and phrase it more for group
G and this is already quite interesting
where if I try to phrase it not for
Curtin type a for GL n but for more
general G things become quite reach so
the corresponding statement would be
that our goal or our presentation of
some
group gene or yeah correspond to
something analogous to what we have seen
before
even though without deeper pursued we
saw that in the case of representation
sometimes conjugacy class is combined
into packets called sheets of Beryl and
Joseph Tony Joseph and here there is
analogous notion of L packets of autumn
Orphic representations for for a
different group so previously it was
n-dimensional versus GL n and now what's
going to happen is that analogous
statement involves different groups so
usually there are not you know to Jeon
ji Chang ji and LG and I'm going to put
wranglin stool on this side since this
is convention used most and most of the
physics literature and this brings an
obvious question what are G n LG and the
answer is the following so you can make
a table that for a group G there is a
corresponding dual called Langlands dual
group and if I'm again treating G
compact group not the reductive as it's
usually used in mathematical or
literature but rather compactly group G
which was my original notation then the
case of GL n should be really cold UN
and in this case the dual group is the
same that's why we didn't need in ocean
in the previous version in the previous
discussion but if you consider already
something more interesting such as as
you
or in mathematics literature you will
see this as SLM case then the
corresponding dual group will be Tsun
which is the same as su n divided by its
center Zn and this is actually the
general property of this duality between
group and its Langlands oh yeah well
this was glory presentations we can
think of it as representation from
Galois group galuwa f bar over f into g
ln so that's basically to say that we
have a non dimensional representation so
that could be in some sense another way
to phrase it and that statement will
have an obvious analogue now right so
this is part of the general dictionary
that for ad type
so G and LG have same car Tantra if
they're of curtain type a de for
instance here we're talking about
curtain type a and that doesn't really
change but what changes is that the
center which shall denote by Z of one
group becomes the fundamental group of
penguins dual and here you see for
instance that su n is simply connected
but has non-trivial Center is the N and
this conversely because it's a quotient
of something connected simply connected
by Zn and has fundamental group but no
longer the center so they exchange their
role and that's a general feature so for
example I can write the case of D so2 n
this is curtain type DN and Langlands
dual is also the same as so 2n and the
same is going to be true for exceptional
groups such as p8 for instance it's self
dual but then once you go to curtain
tribes B and C things again become a
little bit more interesting so for
example SP n is dual to so2 n plus one
that's court untidy that's curtain type
C outside of sync released and for
instance if you take just maybe one more
g2 is going to be fantastic so this is
the notion Franklin's dual group and it
already appears in a classical program
but then that's that's going to be four
and four for physics interpretation and
now I want to kind of start switching
gears even further that we already saw
several spaces appearing in the context
of geometric intention theory these are
usually spaces which have nice sort of
either G symmetry or where G X and in
particular we saw various examples of
sake or joint orbits or conjugacy
classes and this conjugacy classes or
spaces of solutions to some partial
differential equations on Riemann
surfaces so this is the space this is
the place where a Riemann surfaces
appear we already have a lot of groups
erratic data but now I want to introduce
real geometry in a sense of geometric
Langlands of Riemann surfaces which I'm
going to denote by C so C stands for for
for a curve and first observation or
stick notice that if you write kitchens
equations which is a set of partial
differential equations for G bundles and
actions of canonical bundle on a riemann
surface there the higgs field which have
the following form curvature of the
connection is moment map for some Higgs
field Phi then DF Phi is 0 and quite the
f-stop Phi is 0 and denote the moduli
space of solutions to these equations by
m sub h of v G&C so it depends on choice
of group theoretic data group G and the
Riemann surface C then what we saw
before the remark is our orbits
/ conjugacy classes that we already saw
or examples of such moduli spaces where
the Riemann surface is basically
punctured discs so it's a disk with a
puncture yeah specific prescription of
boundary conditions or type of the
puncture and therefore it suggests
natural generalization to move away from
puncture disk which is actually the
statement of local geometric Langlands
to more general Riemann surfaces and
consider same statements as before but
now thinking about such replacement
where you replace a orbit or conjugacy
class by entire hitch and moduli space
force a closed riemann surface see so
that's one way to if you wish enter the
geometric Langlands and its physical
interpretation another way is the
following that the presentations that we
had here are analogs for for if you ask
what what is analog of the Gullah group
for foreign purpose and it also has a
natural counterpart namely in moving
away from this classical case Gua group
has to vary east or if you wish
corresponds to fundamental group of a
riemann surface see okay and if likewise
you ask so previously we're asking what
is the space of representations from
Galois group to some group GE or its
complex version so analogous question
here will be what is the space of
representations of by one of C because
now this is the analog of the Gulag
group into into something say language
duo of C then this again turns well by
definition this is nothing but the space
of complex flat connections on a riemann
surface but
is well known that this is isomorphic in
one of its complex structures to
precisely that same space of solutions
to each an equation for group G or other
LG if I'm using it here on my Riemann
surface II so that's yet another way to
go from classical story to to to to
geometric Langlands and now if you do
that you can make yet another
modification of the statement now in the
context of geometric langlands I'll say
that this is now geometric version that
irreducible G local systems or if you
wish points on this variety on this
space of complex web connections LG in
fact systems on C correspond to okay
again shapes on Bunji
okay so this is the statement of
geometric Langlands and I am Hecky eigen
she is an up your statement to what we
had here and this irreducible G local LG
local system is analog of the Gullah
representation as you see it sounds
horribly complicated but roughly
speaking what it means is that points on
this space here map into something which
behaves nicely with respect to behavior
with respect to analog of the spherical
Hecky algebra which also exists in in
the metric centre and now this brings me
to my last point namely how all of this
should be embedded and in physics we
already got very close by talking about
some gauge theory on a riemann surface
and PDEs and basically we want to
translate so i've been making a slow
path from classical language to
geometric Langlands and now to physics
if you want to study physics approach to
geometric Langlands you can work at
different levels so you have a choice
and and both are okay both are good
possibilities so one level to understand
what this for physicists very
complicated looking statement and
possibly mean is to work with work with
signal model
so there are two levels to understand
the statement so one is signal model a
target space which is each and moduli
space or space of solutions to teach an
equation and the remans you see here and
its counterpart for for the language
dual group so that's one level and the
second option which is closely related
is to work in four-dimensional so-called
N equals 4 super yang-mills which is
formulated for gauge group LG on one
side and leaves on some four dimensional
space which involves product of your
image surface see there's something else
so let's say our two for simply sitting
and here it will be G and it leaves on
same space C cross R 2 and the reason
that such interpretation is even
possible is that if you ask were in
physics and math say this one dual group
appears there are essentially three
places and we have seen all three of
them in this talk so one place is in leg
length correspondence even in classical
version but also in geometric version in
other is in relation between moduli
spaces of solutions to hitchens
equations where this phenomenon is known
as a famous mirror symmetry or example
of famous mirror symmetry
and could've and in fact it was
discovered somewhat independently of any
gauge theory or any other interpretation
or application tool England's where each
of these phases are a non compact local
calabi-yau and you can ask as khalaby
aus and I see the mirror of say this
calabi-yau and what turns out is that
the mirror is precisely the same type of
space but for the dual group that's
basically the key point of the signal
model approach which rests on work of
Thomas causal and Fidel's and in the
context of gauge Theory this is the
third place where England's dual groups
appear namely this interesting theory
for d n equals 4 super yang-mills has
non-trivial duality called s duality
which relates a theory on any four
manifold with the gauge group g to
another theory on the same four manifold
with a Langlands dual group and
basically these three places namely
length length correspondence mirror
symmetry for Hitchin logic spaces and N
equals 4 super yang-mills or the only
three places at least that I know were
Langlands dual groups naturally appear
so if you know yet another application
or yet another aspect or branch of
physics or math where black lines dual
groups naturally come up let me know I
think that's interesting to connect it
but these are pretty much all the spaces
or all the places I know now natural
question then is how do we connect these
three subjects namely Sigma mod of super
meals and our initial starting point
which will be item number three now the
the geometric Langlands correspondence
so these two are related by essentially
compactification on riemann surface e so
if you're physicists you know what I'm
talking about if you're not a physicist
whatever I'm going to say will not shed
much light but this is a fairly standard
separation of compactification or
dimensional reduction on a riemann
surface II and it's actually fun
exercise which was done by your shots ki
Johansen Sudduth and Rafa and then in a
slightly different form by Harvey more
instrument ER to try to spawn
equations of motion or rather bps
equations and n equals 4 super
yang-mills and try to perform the skull
of decline reduction and see what kind
of signal model you get as a result and
of course they find that from N equals 4
super yang-mills you get precisely the
signal model in the Hitchin moduli space
and moreover they were the what who
actually from physics point of view
proposed that as duality becomes Chi
duality or mirror symmetry in the signal
model context so this two are related by
fairly clear operation so then let's see
how we can rephrase this geometric
langlands in the language say of a sigma
mod and there will be analogous
formulation in terms of in terms of
gauge Theory any any questions so
this is the last point and we already
very very close in fact I kind of gave
you a hint of what's going to happen so
this G local systems on C are basically
point-like objects in our points on this
hitch and modulate space so what we're
trying to ask is what happens to a point
under mirror symmetry that's that's the
question where they really ask them so
let's see what No
not entirely so the way we're going to
reformulate that still will be quite at
the metric so in fact right as duality
as symmetric is a symmetric but then
question is what do we ask what what
exact question we ask and the exact
questions that we ask will actually be
quite us in it maybe I'll try to
summarize it now that was my plan and
you'll see for yourself that it's not
exactly the same so yeah I'm debating
what to raise I guess where is this part
so there are a couple of observations
bank two to make a physics counterpart
of that it's mental England's conjecture
that's still on the board so first of
all every point in each and moduli space
mhm for a length lens dual group I just
decided to name gallo aside with the LG
so I hope it's a lot of problems in G
has to come in somewhere Oh point I want
to point up is object is fairly nice in
fact it's a holomorphic in all complex
structures of hitch and moduli space and
it carries infinitely many so it's a
pretty cool thing it's try holomorphic
this terminology has to do with the fact
that usually this infinite set of
complex structures is expressed in terms
of standard basis of Phi J and K and
then that's that's what try refers to
and this is can be also phrased by by
saying that it's a certain object namely
brain of type BBB okay
because be brains in the story that's
involves mirror symmetry and that you
probably heard a lot more about
from Rhonda Nagi or ya be brains or
holomorphic and the corresponding
complex structure so for the natural
setting for this right hand side left
hand side of the correspondence is is
the set of this BB big brains on on MMH
for Langlands dual group so let's take
this as an approximation for our
correspondence and ask what's going to
be on the right hand side here we have
to think a little bit because physical
setup indeed is somewhat symmetric
that's what you're pointing out and most
moduli space on both sides but here we
actually don't even see each and moduli
space or anything similar so just like
here we have to do some interpretation
so it should be the fact that Bungie
which we don't have to know what it is
is half dimensional space in fact the
most interesting part in some sense of
kitchen space and you can say that M
hitch and space for Group G on a riemann
surface scene is roughly speaking but
this is huge roughly so that's a big lie
and I hope that Satoshi will tell us a
lot more and you'll see actually very
explicitly how much it is a lie cat
engine bundle to Bungie total space of
the cotangent bundle to Bungie
so therefore already have some
connection but in order to really bridge
the gap between Bungie or other t-star
Bungie and hitch and moduli space we
have to say that such Hecky eigen
sheaves or more precisely D modules in
this setting actually can be realized as
a brains on on the dual space and
therefore the corresponding statement
will be that here we're looking for
brains of type
let's see B
a brains on mh4 the group G on the
riemann surface see okay yeah yeah so
the first one in the notations of
Hitchin is actually fixed because in
this complex structure this mirror
symmetry is a free mo chi transform it's
actually a holomorphic operation but
it's honesty to ality and which in a
sense of nourishing if you're it's a
brain and brains and other complex
structures so that's actually what we
expect here because it's whatever this
high key eigen she is are there supposed
to be more like a brains or other the
support of a gmod was basically there a
brain so it is a symmetric already here
that you should think of this side which
was originally galore as b-model side
where there is auto morphic side is
supposed
be a model and as you can guess a model
is usually more complicated than B model
and same as brewery number theory
context what amorphic side is more
complicated and Lois I know roughly
speaking usually in addition it wouldn't
be good enough if we didn't have this
action of Hecky algebra so remember that
algebra of symmetric functions metric
polynomials so it's a commutative
algebra and in physics it's realized as
algebra fuels and lines algebra Wilson
operators oh sorry approved operators
I'm jumping ahead of myself and that
were not signal model but rather gauge
Theory comes handy because it
immediately says that under this s
duality truth decorators may happen to
those operators and in fact it's a fun
exercise to verify that is point like
BBB brains are in fact eigen brains with
respect to action of this algebra of
Wilson operators and the two tats
mapping to each other with respect to as
duality or or or this near asymmetry so
to summarize and sorry for or actually
I'm pretty much on time to summarize
what this physics interpretation of
geometric Langlands does it basically is
a package that really it's different
types of brains a brains versus B brains
on hitch and moduli spaces for the group
GN language dual group and this map is
consistent with an action of Hecky
algebras of various types here we
encountered so called spherical Hecky
algebra which i mentioned before and
again that was a commutative algebra
the reason it is commutative is because
from the physics point of view this may
be helpful to physicists if you try to
take PE of line operators in
four-dimensional space it doesn't matter
whether you approach line 1 and line 2
in this water or this water you can move
them around you have a lot of space
around to move them so that's why
corresponding Hecky algebra is spherical
which means commutative but the moment
you have something which favors a
play-in on which this line operator is a
stock and in the physics context this
additional data usually comes in the
form of Sur operator that will lead to
generalization of this algebra and jolin
ization of this story which will have
non commutative fatty algebra namely
various forms of a fine head culture so
the last thing I want to make the last
remark is that ramification which means
that on a riemann surface scene you have
our particular points where something
that happens and in numb basically case
from education is unavoidable so you
have to consider such case in general
this is realized in physics corresponds
to surface operators which in our story
or supported points on this riemann
surface and span the other two
dimensions which I called our 2d for so
you have this kind of two-dimensional
support of a surface operator and now if
you try to ask for two line operators
say line 1 and line 2 to a form or PE
and we take a product and one order and
compare it to the opposite order they
don't necessarily have to agree and what
this ope tells you is actually giving
you various versions of non spherical
Hecky algebra such as a fine and various
other deformations
and I promise you that you will you'll
recognize some of the words and topics
that were mention in various hot talks
for example do pay will tell you a lot
about map of a brains and B brains and
that is geometric langlands duality so
basically he'll zoom in on one
particular aspect and in the lecture of
Satoshi you'll see what spherical really
means and why am kitchen is not quite
the same as T store open G right thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
so is there an intrinsic immortal
interpretation of this hekia bruh terms
of the foci category arson yes there is
so in them in both a model and B model
you can think of Hecky algebra as oh
yeah there's corresponding operators as
functors acting on fukaya category and
derived category so the rough version of
this question would be what are the auto
equivalences of say foci category here
in the right editor here that's not
quite the question we really want to ask
because we care about this particular
brains so it's not the other equivalents
of the entire category but rather this
is a special class of brains so that's
that's the question that you would
consider on either a side and B side and
you can realize some of them some of
these functors as correspondences
especially on ice so your original
discussion or ''but method for various
groups and in particular you have a
version of all this story for for other
types of groups when the base field is
not algebraically closed and so we have
geometric Langlands the geometric Satake
for real groups and we understand very
well how the geometry for those works is
there a version of the supersymmetric h
theory that would make sense for non
CompactRIO forms is some oriented
folding process that you can perform
that
correspond exactly say to the the
geometrics attack you for real groups or
the language for each other actually two
questions that you package in one so one
is how does do the highlights of
geometric representation Theory embed
into the story and I wouldn't mention
them in the beginning if they didn't so
they they they do and that's a beautiful
rich story so you can embed relation to
representations of say group G not
meaning now compact understand II in
fact in real group and geometric say
taki correspondence and in both cases
this additional gadgets or animals that
live in the zoo of four-dimensional
theory such as surface I territories and
other defects come in so I didn't really
have much time to explain it but they're
still there and you mentioned also the
second one more remark I want to make on
your question related to oriented fold
so that that's really in some sense yet
another subject which one could have
talked about how so here we I focused on
two-dimensional story of a Sigma model
and a four-dimensional story of a gauge
theory but you could ask how does it
Rico is it realized in string theory
because you can realize this N equals 4
super yang-mills on the world volume of
the three brains and the natural
question so that that would lead only to
curtain type a by default so you can ask
what do I do to get other curtain types
and how do I relate SL to Z quality of N
equals 4 super yang-mills to analogous
duality of type to B string theory so
that would indeed involve oriented folds
and actually will be highly non-trivial
so for a long time I thought that they
just trivially coins for example type to
be coupling constantly becomes coupling
constant on on the three brains or
something like that and they transform
in a similar way but actually that's not
true and unfortunately this is not
the literature I want to advertise that
for non simply laced types which you
mentioned involving oranga Falls that's
actually somewhat very subtle story I
was thinking of whether I should mention
it or not and the talk I'll be happy to
discuss it privately but that's
surprisingly so embedding this and 10
dimensional type to be is yet another
subject which currently in the
literature even in the most reference
papers is not quite quite well described
I'm not quite correct well that's true
and that's why I always thought that I
understood and that embedding is very
trivial but it's it's actually
surprisingly is not so over the past
year we had intense discussion with you
did you G Tachikawa and in fact some of
the questions that I emailed you
occasionally are related to that
discussion so that's why we were
interested in or in default and this
embedding is highly non-trivial so
therefore I want to separate two parts
of your question to one part the answer
is that it has been studied and it's
somewhat documented in literature but
the other part surprisingly is something
I didn't touch at all and actually there
is a lot to say for non simple simply
laced groups so I'm betting in time to
be is highly non-trivial
on the a model side so basically these
conditions which are something like
hurried use usually means that your
brain has one component so that's that's
typically what it means so an a model
side it will mean that it's not direct
some but some of these notions become
blurry because you quickly pass from
individual objects to from individual
brains or some manifolds to objects on
the theorized category so we actually
have to consider not just say just joint
union of two lagrangians but actually
derived version of the foci category and
therefore complexes and so on so that's
again I didn't want to mention
categories that much but usually it is
this notion of irreducibility becomes
either blurry or replaced by something
else in a categorical world that's
that's more precise yes yeah so in this
case well anyway yeah in fact if I were
to discuss or fully I would only have to
go into stacks and that's a territory
that's the best described and work of
denying contest that would be actually
that's more useful also related to
answering question about non simply
laced cases so that something I want to
advertise
well we didn't say it's really classical
because if it was really classical you
know the whole even even at the level of
signal model the whole mirror symmetry
program would be simple and classical
but but it's not really so it is
somewhat classical if you think about it
in complex structure I where it's free a
Mook I transform but even that now is
applied who varieties with lots of
singular fibers and you have to yeah
it's not entirely classical yes no no
that's that's precisely what we touched
just a moment ago so in fact if you
start asking again it depends I think
that the honest answer is depends on how
deep you look if you ask for say generic
point here skyscraper shape this bpb
brain at a very generic point things are
relatively nice and you can limit
yourself to that and the victory and
then people of course want something
interesting a peculiar so they tend to
send these points into singular points
on the hitch and modular space where
there are singular fibers and again I'm
sure you'll hear more about this it's
not from citta Chien and then from do
pay and then question becomes what do we
do with the singular points so geometry
of target becomes singular so something
has to come to the rescue
so engage there it comes to the rescue
so that's where zooming on those
questions and find transfer them will
require on a mathematical side language
of Stax or something else that can
answer it and physics behind is really
the gauge theory
a gauge coupling enters questions which
are usually referred as quanta metric
Langlands and trying to make both sides
indeed more on equal footing so in that
case what happens is that it's not just
B side and a side as cleanly as I
described today both are kind of
deformed so that completely different
kind of form opens up related to and if
noncommutative deformation of brains on
the one hand and again in the math
literature this is quantum geometric
langlands and the gauge coupling or more
precisely the parameter that Kapusta
Newton called sigh enters the story in
the crucial way but yeah that's another
husband
no it's yeah but don't underestimate
Anning they decide and poof dr. Reiter
is is highly non-trivial I think there
is this a brains and and whose
typewriters that's that's not classical
its if you really want to answer it and
full glory that's that's Esquire yet
[Applause]